it's been well over a month since the
release of the galaxy s 20 ultra and
while this phone itself is actually a
killer phone the launch of it was I'd
say quite unfortunate it was clear from
the very beginning that Samsung was
taking a pretty big risk on the ultra I
mean they priced it at a starting price
of $1400 and that's quite expensive even
compared to the best iPhones out there
which have themselves been criticized
for being too expensive
since the thousand-dollar iPhone 10 so
Samsung knowing how big of a risk this
was put all of their chips in the
marketing campaign of the s20 ultras new
features like the cameras and 5g making
it seem like this was the best
smartphone on the market now if your
smartphone is so good that it can prove
itself as the best smartphone in the
world
then the $1400 price tag might be
justified and people will buy it this
was the trick that Apple pulled with the
iPhone 10 at release it was the most
expensive smartphone ever but because it
was so good it actually was the
best-selling smartphone of the year but
in the case of the Galaxy S tony ultra a
couple of very unfortunate things
happened that nobody was expecting but
before I get into that I want to talk
about the s20 ultra itself and what I
really enjoyed about this phone since we
got our hands on it first off I love the
design it's just so fine-tuned compared
to before I personally love large camera
bumps and I feel like the one on the s20
ultra just seems so substantial and
premium I also like the button layout
with all the buttons being on one side
and the power button being in the
perfect spot for my thumb and I
absolutely love the massive 6.9 inch
display Samsung really nailed it this
year with the subtle and clean looking
hole punch camera in the center instead
of on the side this looks so much
cleaner than the iPhones knotch
that's getting quite a bit old already
and Samsung managed to pull off really
thin bezels while also not curving the
display as much as before this is great
because I no longer touch the edges of
the display like I did with the s10 plus
and the display itself is just amazing
it's super bright in its very color
accurate as
well the sheer size of it actually makes
it a decent device to watch Netflix on
and then couple that with incredibly
loud speakers and you've got the best
phone for watching videos and I'm still
extremely impressed with how Samsung
managed to make the earphone speakers so
loud while being so thin that it's
almost invisible I honestly think that
the ask Tony altra is the best phone for
gaming that's ever been made because of
the combination of the massive display
the excellent speakers the subtle
hole-punch camera and the new 120 Hertz
display I played three different games
on both the iPhone 11 Pro Max and the
s20 ultra for an hour each to test the
battery life of each of these phones
even though the Ultra was running these
games at 120 Hertz while the iPhone was
running them at 60 the ultra drained
just a little bit more battery life
which was extremely impressive and it
did it while running the game smoothly
and the phone itself didn't heat up as
much as the iPhone so for all those
reasons it's the best phone for gaming
yet now in terms of performance both the
iPhone and the s2000 are now so fast
that it really doesn't improve the
everyday experience of using the phone
any more than last year's models but
what does improve it is the 120 Hertz
display this feature by itself makes the
ultra feel so much more snappy compared
to the iPhone when swiping through your
home screen or scrolling through apps
like Facebook and it's also nice to know
that you've got top-of-the-line specs
like 12 or 16 gigs of ram Wi-Fi 6 IP 68
water resistance and 5g connectivity for
those who agree with that and now the
only thing I haven't mentioned is the
biggest thing that Samsung marketed the
world's best camera system and with this
camera system Samsung took a major risk
but before I get into what happened with
the cameras I want to get into the first
unfortunate thing that happened when
Samson launched the s20 ultra they
couldn't have made the risk of launching
a $1400 phone at a worse time
the corona virus pandemic turned out
quite a bit worse than we all expected
with the economy taking a massive hit
the national multi-family housing
council recently released
showing that nearly one-third of us
apartment renters didn't pay the rent at
all in April showing just how bad the
economy has gotten in such a short
amount of time so the truth of the
matter is if the economy is suffering
this badly who is gonna be buying a
brand new cell phone let alone one that
costs $1,400 a couple of weeks ago
Samsung held a private conference call
where they reportedly saw very
disappointing sales of the galaxy s 20
series phones and while they haven't
released official sales numbers yet it's
estimated that they only sold 60% of the
sales of the s10 Series last year now I
know that it's not just Samsung phones
taking a hit the entire smartphone
industry got hit as well including Apple
with researchers expecting global
consumers to purchase 33 million fewer
phones this year so with all that out of
the way let's get into the second
unfortunate thing that happens at the
launch of the s20 altra they focused way
too much marketing on the camera making
it seem like the s Tony all sure had by
far the best camera on any smartphone so
with that came massive expectations from
consumers and initial reviewers however
they also chose to put in a brand new
camera system that they've never used
before and because of that this software
wasn't ready for the release so when
reviewers got their hands on the S 20
ultra almost every initial review
mentioned camera issues especially with
auto focusing this is really bad news
for Samsung since quite a lot of people
decided to wait until the issues were
resolved before investing $1,400 into
this phone we tried it ourselves and ran
a blind test comparing the s20 ultra the
s 20 plus and the note 10 plus which
quickly became very popular gating
almost half a million views and
surprisingly the note actually won the
test at that point
Samsung promised a huge software update
that would fix the camera for good and
now over a month later that software
update finally came so just recently we
did another camera test before and after
the
update to see what's changed and while
it did improve the autofocus performance
is nowhere near where it should be and
much worse compared to the iPhone 11 pro
max so the camera performance is still
disappointing after that update so maybe
they have more camera updates planned I
don't know but now that it's been five
and a half weeks since we received the
phone it's honestly too late the s20
ultras reputation has already been
damaged so much especially in this
economy that I don't think the sales of
this phone will ever recover but let's
pretend for a minute that the camera was
so good that it blew every phone away in
that case this would probably be the
phone of the year but with the camera
that is nowhere near as good as Samson
said it would be even people who have
the extra cash to buy the s20 ultra
should just buy something else like the
s20 plus now that phone is actually
great so if you want to see our review
of the s20 plus tap the like' button and
click the circle above to subscribe so
you don't miss out on that review and
make sure to check out our s20 ultra
camera comparisons right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]